to better understand how we can factor
second-degree expressions like this I'm
going to go through some examples we'll
factor this expression and we'll factor
this expression and hopefully it'll give
you a background how you could generally
factor expressions like this and to
think about it let's think about what
happens if I were to multiply X plus
something times X plus something else
well if I were to multiply this out what
do I get
well you're going to get x squared plus
ax plus BX which is the same thing as a
plus B X plus a times B plus a B so if
you wanted to go from this form if you
want to go from this form which is what
we have in these two examples back to
this you really just have to think about
well what's our coefficient on our X
term and can I figure out two numbers
that are equal to when I that when I
take their sum are equal to that
coefficient and what's my constant term
and can I think of two numbers those
same two numbers that when I take the
product equal that constant term so
let's do that over here if we look at
our X coefficient the coefficient on X
can we think of an A plus a B that is
equal to that number negative 14 and can
we think of the same a and B that if we
were to take its product it would be
equal to 40 it would be equal to 40 so
what's an A and a B that would work over
here well let's think about this a
little bit if I have 4 times 10 is 40
but 4 plus 10 is equal to positive 14 so
that wouldn't quite work but what
happens if we make them both negative if
we have negative 4 plus negative 10 well
that's going to be equal to negative 14
and negative 4 times negative 10 times
negative 10 is equal to is equal to 40
the fact that this number right over
here is positive this number right over
here is positive tells you that these
are going to be the same sign so these
are going to be the same sign these are
going to have the exact same sign and
this number right over here was negative
then we would have different signs and
so if you have two numbers that are
going to be the same sign and they add
to a negative number then that tells you
that they're both going to be negative
so just going back to this we know that
a is going to be negative for B is equal
to negative 10 and we are done factoring
it we can factor this expression as X
plus negative 4x plus negative 4 times X
plus negative 10 or another way to write
that that's X minus 4 times X minus 10
now let's do the same thing over here
can we think of an a plus B and a plus B
that's equal to the coefficient on the
x-term well the coefficient on the X
term here it's this is essentially
negative 1 times X so we can say the
coefficient is negative 1 and can we
think of an a times B where it's going
to be equal to a times B is equal to
negative 12 is equal to negative 12 well
let's think about this a little bit the
product of the two numbers is negative
so that means that they have different
signs so dif different different signs
so one will be positive and one will be
negative and so when I add them two
together I get two negative one well
just think about the factors of negative
12 well what about if one is three and
maybe one is negative four well that
seems to work and you really just have
to try these numbers out if a is 3 so 4
3 plus negative 4 that indeed turns out
to be negative 1 and if we have 3 times
negative 4 that indeed is equal to
negative 12 so that seems to work out
and it's really a matter of trial and
error you could try negative 3 plus 4
but then that wouldn't have worked out
over here you could have tried 2 & 6 but
that would wouldn't have worked out on
this number you wouldn't have got or 2
and negative 6 you wouldn't have gotten
the sum to be equal to negative 1
but now that we have we figured out what
the a and B are what is this expression
factored well it's going to be X plus 3
times X plus negative 4 or we could say
X minus 4